I sent a tweet it was last November I
think about you know the film Mary
Poppins it's a motor problem Julie
Andrews I've seen it was resina right so
she ends up with a covered with chimney
soot on her eyes and so titania tweeted
saying this was blackface the picture of
Julie Andrews with Jim you said this is
black place it's disgusting and then
five months later the New York Times ran
an article saying exactly that right now
I predicted it and it's almost like I'm
not saying I've got magical powers or
anything but it is that thing of you
know what how can you win the when real
life is catching up with you so much
there's virtually nothing that I could
tweet that eventually won't happen this
is the Reuben report and according to
the Senate inquiry I'm Dave Rubin quick
reminder guys that the Reuben report app
is here just search Reuben report in the
App Store or on Google Play and join our
troll free community where you can get
ad free video and audio podcasts connect
with other viewers and even little ol me
for more info go to Reuben report come
out more importantly than that joining
me today is a comedian author and
dissector of social justice
Andrew Doyle welcome to the Reuben
report nice to see ya
how's it going it is going well I feel
this is overdue for many reasons okay
cuz you know as a guy that came from the
left and started saying these people are
no longer liberal yeah what's this
social justice thing and
intersectionality and all of it yeah you
are sort of the the king or the queen
don't misgender me but it's one or the
other yeah sure I think I love this you
were gonna clear the queen of this thing
I mean I've had that similar that I mean
I'm accused of often going over to the
right which isn't really the case you
know I don't see you know I come from a
leftist background but I I think that
conservatives are right about some
things I think left-wing people are
right about other things and you know I
think if you subscribe to an ideology
wholesale and you just say that's me I'm
gonna agree with those points then
you're not really thinking for yourself
and that scares me a little bit so I
don't do that yeah all right well we're
gonna have to clean up some of that in
the course of this next hour now and the
little confused though because when when
we were pitched you yes this is your
book well it's the Townies book well so
this is the the confusion so I thought
that we were having to Tanya McGrath on
the show yeah she's not available
and it's called woke and it's a guide to
social justice yeah and I thought we
were having miss McGrath yeah yeah here
we end up with you so I'm a little
confused can you possibly dissect this
for me well she's out and about she's
doing her protesting I guess she's
probably gluing herself to someone's
front door who's considered a and
negative influence on society you know
that's her kind of thing but actually
the truth is she doesn't exist you know
so she I created her flow in my mind I
know it's not it's not a revelation
really yeah she it was April 2018 and I
thought I'm gonna create a fake
character to satirize the social justice
movement well the excesses of the social
justice movement you know and so I
wanted to do this sort of slam poet very
pretentious young very narcissistic kind
of very privileged person who wants to
nevertheless say that she's oppressed so
reveling in oppression and victimhood
and all of that stuff you know this is
quite a recognizable type of person yes
seeing one or two people on the Twitter
and they're kind of funny you know
because there's a lot of them
particularly UK there's a lot of these
sort of left-leaning people they write
tend to write for things like The
Guardian and the independent and they're
very all about their victim status but
they come from sort of independently
millionaire backgrounds and they don't
see that that's funny I find that
hilarious and of course they are fully
and the other thing about them of course
if they don't they don't want to sit and
debate and reason and talk and so
therefore the best thing to do I think
is mop them and poke fun of them and the
hope was but if I presented their own
sort of failings to them through this
caricature who obviously says things
that are beyond what most normal people
say it is as sort of character is an
extreme but I thought it might maybe
start some kind of process of
self-reflection potentially it doesn't
it just seems to have got them angry
well it's funny because when I see -
Tanya's Twitter account when I first saw
it so this is now a year and a half ago
or so it's hard to tell what satire no
more because the things that you or she
is tweeting about they sound very much
like the stuff that were constantly
thrown at by mainstream media actually
even though you're trying to be
over-the-top and oh yeah and quite
absurd when it catches up I mean so I'm
telling my face like so I give an
example they say I sent a tweet
it was last November I think about you
know the film Mary Poppins it's a motor
problem Judy Andrea I've seen it was
heard or seen aright so she ends up with
a covered with chimney soot on her eyes
and so titania tweeted saying this was
blackface the picture of Julie Andrews
with Jim you said this is black place
it's disgusting and then five months
later the New York Times ran an article
saying exactly that right now I'd
predicted it and it's almost like I'm
not saying I've got magical powers or
anything but it is that thing of you
know what how can you wonder when real
life is catching up with you so much
there's virtually nothing that I could
tweet that eventually won't happen and
then when I did a joke tweet about the
Queen it was the Queen's Speech at
Christmas and I was saying that she
should the listing the things she should
have said and I was saying that she
should have said what about the new
Royal baby and how it should be raised
as gender-fluid yeah and then lo and
behold that was raised by Megan a few
months later it's like well I you know I
on one side it's funny and then it also
depresses me a little bit that these
things happen okay so before we get too
far into the psychology yeah can you
just explain a little bit of your back
and as you said you grew up kind of kind
of lefty comedy all of that stuff just
react for the people that don't know
okay yeah so um I've been a writer for a
long time but I started out in academia
and I wanted to get out of that pretty
quickly you teach I was teaching
Shakespeare I was teaching the
Shakespeare mantra Oxford University was
there a connection between the social
justice thing and wanting to get out a
teacher well I'm I was in Wotton College
at Oxford which is the most sort of it's
known for being the most woke College
Oxford College before the word work was
even being used by most people it wasn't
connected no it was it was you know I I
I just thought thought I'm stuck in
libraries all the time it's quite
depressing and I thought I'd better get
out of that so I went out I started
writing this sort of comedy plays and
doing stand-up in London and then I I
ran out of money and I had nothing so I
was teaching so I took up sort of
secondary school teaching I did that for
about seven years and all the while I
was doing stand-up and all the while I
was writing plays and writing stuff like
that so that's my sort of background and
I've been on the comedy circuit for a
long time in about 15 years now
so how woke is Oxford generally because
I've seen I was there a couple times
when I was on tour with Jordan and I
spoke at Oxford Union and I thought the
questions were we're really rich and
interesting but then you could feel that
there is this strain of something
getting into the
this greatest place of higher learning
like this scary thing well this there's
evidence to suggest that the most
privileged student the most privileged
people the richest in other words are
far more likely to be social justice
activists right and spikes online does a
survey of universities every year and
every single year it's determined that
the ones that are the worst offenders
when it comes to censorship when it
comes to free speech tend to be from the
kids who were the poshest who have the
most stuff right so it's not really
surprising that you get them the woke
elements at Oxford but as a kind of
caveat to that what I would say is I you
know I do talks at universities around
the country and what I've noticed is the
kids are often great and they're often
not these sort of snowflakes that people
make them out to be they're not they
want to be challenged and the number the
people that I've spoken to they want to
be challenged they want to they want to
hear the other side even if they don't
necessarily agree it's generally the
academics right I did a talk at an at
university recently where the students
were great they wanted to be challenged
but then the the the politics Department
refused to publicize my appear or her
because they said any talk that was
antithetical to what culture was against
their diversity policy so they they
refute boycotted it completely so I
often find it's my generation that are
the worst when it comes to this stuff
how old are you I'm fine if you don't
mind me not at all you're a gen Xer like
mine I I'm a gen Xer yeah yeah yeah you
know it's so interesting because I agree
with that even though we see the
snowflakes of colleges and the screaming
people and the means of all that stuff
but it does seem to really come from the
academic layer I was giving a talk about
six months ago at a school and a guy
came up to me after he was older than an
average college student and he told me
that he was a veteran and he started
college late he said that he was in a
philosophy class earlier in the day and
the philosophy professor instructed them
not to go to Dave Reubens all right talk
Wow that evening and he said he said I'm
a little older than these students so I
didn't want to embarrass the teacher in
front of class so I went up to him after
and I said can you tell me what all
right opinions they had been hold and
the professor basic said well I don't
know but I've read that yeah sure and he
was like I tried to ask get the
professor to come here but then of
course he wouldn't come and the rest of
it but yeah the idea that they're just
being hit with this stuff I mean there's
when they when they're the most
impression exactly but some on some of
the university I think
it takes a certain degree of education
to say things like that because because
it's stupidity it's a kind of learning
stupidity which is really it's really
odd isn't it
and I think it's because when I was at
university there was all this kind of
post-structuralism
there was all this kind of focus on
dairy down Foucault and all that kind of
thing and it was sort of dying off a few
years ago and now that's gone mainstream
and I don't know why I find that really
weird do you have suspicions as to why
it's good being through many theories I
don't know why and I'm often asking this
question I do want to know what it is I
I I can't fathom it actually I don't
know why it involves a kind of
substitution of slogans for a lack of
thought you know so you get these
phrases like lived-experience better why
right here yeah so what this means is
you know when you discuss this stuff
with whether social justice activists i
guarante when i talk to a social justice
activist i know what their opinion is
about absolutely everything as soon as
i've said one thing they're just
repeating a script and that to me is
really that's not freedom of thought
right that's that's that's an
ideological adherence and they use these
phrases and then when you challenge them
on the phrases they don't know what to
do with that to then lived experiences
just well that's that ends the
discussion right well actually lived
experience we used to call that
anecdotal evidence and we used to
dismiss it right you know but now we
actually it has some kind of weird wait
it's if you come up with these sort of
phrase it's these sort of phrases that
have this kind of academic sound about
this jargon this intersectional quality
it's a way of giving weight or
ostensible weight to very flimsy ideas
that's what it is so it's like it's like
a kind of substitute for thought so
before we go too far into those flimsy
ideas yeah I've listed all the words
that you've got on the book here I can't
your take on all these yo but just for
the for the few people that might be
watching this go oh Reubens got another
right wing neuron to talk about how evil
the social justice words are when you're
when you say you come sort of from the
left from a UK perspective what does
that actually mean and maybe how is that
a little different than the American
perspective
well liberal means something different
in the UK I mean bottom line I guess
where I fall on the spectrum well
firstly what I should say is I don't
think there's anything wrong with being
conservative so when people say I'm a
conservative I'm like well so what yeah
you know that's fine I don't happen to
be but I don't see an issue if I were if
I were I would just own the label it's
not a problem be along
to get to that part if I exact well but
you know it is partly it's because they
first caught they call you a series of
other much worse so all you far-right
and all right and then when when the
average person realizes that doesn't
stick then they just throw conservative
and at that point it's like alright you
want to call me conservative but they
throw those much they don't know what
they mean I mean oh right it's really
easy to check you know you all right is
white nationalist you know then you
can't get away from those connotations
yeah you're not know so you can take
that one off okay so yeah so if I was to
say where am i politically it's
somewhere between what would say social
liberalism
and socialism somewhere dancing around
that but with I'm quite culturally
conservative so there's elements of that
as well
but I guess I you know I believe in the
welfare state I believe in proportionate
taxation for people who are earning more
not to excess but just enough to
definitely moral Epling that me right
sure I'll give it to you so the kind I
kind of just to curb the excesses of
capitalism but not about out you know
get rid of it entirely yeah I believe in
equality of opportunity I believe in
social equal rights and human rights and
so all of those sort of things which I
think on the whole put me in that
left-wing bracket I'm not um
instinctively nationalistic although I
understand why people are yeah I just
don't have that in me but I don't think
it's a poisonous thing so is the problem
for someone that holds those sorta so
that what that sounds to me is sort of
like an old-school Democrat you want
some social programs and curb what you
might see or the excesses of capitalism
want to cut the excesses of the state
like I don't trust the state right so
that so that's sort of interesting
because it's sort of like that to me is
what we would call here a Blue Dog
Democrat that you don't want the state
to do everything now I don't really have
those Democrats saying I won the state
stay out of people's private lines oh
you know I find that I you know we've in
the UK they've already proven that they
don't they can't be trusted on all sorts
of issues you know the fact that they're
criminalizing people who tell certain
jokes for instance the fact that they
don't see the difference between jokin
and the literal truth that means that to
me I don't want them getting involved in
curbing people's of speech you know and
I think that the free spirit mean you've
got a First Amendment you're okay yeah
so no for now we don't have that we have
an unwritten Constitution which means
it's constantly being reinterpreted and
sometimes quite badly so as a free
speech guy and a guy that out there is
doing pretty
travursel stuff how cognizant are you
aware that you don't have the First
Amendment right so comedians here you
can say whatever you want yeah you know
every time Trump tweets these edgy
comedians tweet you know they tell them
to you know go kiss off or yeah yeah
whatever yeah because every running
Trump doesn't send the police
the Gestapo doesn't knock on the door
you're good to go yeah but in the UK you
don't have certain protection we okay so
it doesn't affect me so much so I've
never made the claim that I'm being
silenced right I'm actually a really
privileged position I don't have a boss
I can say whatever I want I'm a comedian
and a writer so I do say whatever I want
I've never felt that I'm being censored
the concern is that actually the people
who do I mean look say if I was still a
teacher could I send the tweets that I
send at the moment absolutely not I
would get in a lot of trouble I know
people who who have got in trouble at
work because I think jokes they've made
or things that have been misconstrued a
lot of people over in the UK are now
talking to their friends at work over
whatsapp which means that their jokes
get encrypted right so that's really
weird isn't the idea you must encrypt
your jokes I mean you know haze there by
a company that's owned by Facebook right
right there we go yeah that's great yeah
so I mean on the whole I think we do
have freedoms but I don't think there's
a big freedom of speech crisis what I
mean is it you have to be vigilant about
it you have to be careful and you have
to stand up and we've got a situation
where the police are there was a guy in
homicide who retweeted a poem which was
deemed to be transphobic and then the
police phoned him up and said we need to
check your thinking on this and he said
well what's my crime and they said and
I'm not kidding they said this is a non
crime hate incident and that's standard
police practice so that's that so that's
a worry well so every few weeks I see
one of those tweets it's usually from
the Sussex police right is that is that
who it's all over the minutes it's it's
it's West Yorkshire Police it's been the
Glasgow police as well it's very police
department they literally tweet out
things like if someone that you know
said something that you might have taken
offense to yes let us know right exactly
and I mean much more Orwellian can you
guess right and and you know whenever
you use that word Orwellian people say
you're being cliched but there is no
other word for it what else are you
gonna call it this is this is that's
exactly what it is so so while I'm
saying you know this isn't
to the point of a kind of authoritarian
state right but when you see these
things you have to stand up and say no
this is it you know we can't have this
we've got to get rid of this and and if
you don't that's where the slippery
slope begins what do you think it's
partially that people just don't stand
up so for example you can't doing what
you're doing we know Douglas Mari and
Peter Lloyd and Paul Joseph Watson I
mean there's a plenty of people all over
the political spectrum yeah do stand up
to it they haven't grabbed people and
brought them to the gulags yet but it's
just like we just need more people to
stand up and then they'll well kind of
paper tiger disappear I think the trick
is you've got to stand up for people you
don't like and that's the I mean what I
mean it what my understand why people
don't want to don't want to stand up for
the right thing I don't know there's a
thing called preference falsification
where you you say what you think is
going to be best received as opposed to
what you actually think and I understand
that impulse because I mean it's a
protection is its kind of shield but if
everyone's a bit more courageous and you
know when I defend someone's right to
say something and I don't like what
they've said in the invariably I get I
get told that I'm endorsing what they've
said so this is fundamental to
misunderstanding I think generally with
free speech is a kind of fundamental
misunderstanding of what of what it is
you know nobody is saying there
shouldn't be consequences to speech
nobody's saying that they're saying that
if you're consequent if you want to
argue back ridicule whatever you know
that's a protest even that's great great
all for it right it's when you get the
police involved you know and it's not
the same as perjury or libel laws or
those kind of things which all
harassment although which are already
covered by law you know we talk about
you know and the other one I get all the
time is though well you can't shout fire
in a theater actually you can but you're
a bit of a [ __ ]
gonna be honest if you do that that the
the theater authorities are well within
their rights to ask you to leave right
there's a little there's a little
confusion like some legal confusion that
has sort of become lore about the fire
in a crowded theater it's not it's not
true yeah you incite a riot basically is
the right like there's some so with the
incitement of honest thing I'd like I
imagine there are circumstances where
there's a mob and someone's you know
talking to the mob and saying go and get
that person yeah well there you can't do
right sure so we have laws that cover
incitement to violence but the trouble
is and this is another example of the
state getting it wrong so recently we
had to debate in the UK Parliament
because Boris Johnson the Conservatives
were using language like the surrender
bill to describe a bill that relates to
the the brixon negotiations and they
were accused of using
military language which incites violence
it's called a metaphor right honestly
though so many people on the sort of
liberal left social justice group they
don't understand basic metaphor they
don't understand it they don't
understand jokes right they they they
take them completely literally right
there's an example of this that there's
a comedian called Andrew Lawrence in the
UK who posted a joke online and I'll say
what the joke is probably is offensive
right so this was the joke so the
journal
yeah brace yourself right yes okay so
the joke was basically that the the
statistics on suicide between men and
women are not comparable and so you know
more men kill themselves than women so
therefore feminists really care about
equality they should kill them secretly
now are they okay right now it's not the
joke and it's not people being offended
I think people should be allowed to be
offended and they've got the right to be
offended that's not the issue there was
a petition which called for him to be
you know D platform from the BBC even
prosecuted and what they said was this
was inciting women to kill themselves
right now if your opinion of women is
that low yeah but you think they're so
stupid that there is just these little
drones that just will kill themselves
they hear a joke about it and that
concerns me this kind of literal
mindedness about metaphor about jokes
about art you know you get that in
Hollywood all the time like we need to
represent women in a certain way so
let's make the Charlie's Angels reboot
which nobody wants to see because it's
just it's clearly social engineering
it's clearly you people you're you're
you you think the wrong way and we wear
that with the Hollywood people we're
going to tell you how you should be
thinking yeah people it's so if that is
rhubarb ative to people it just puts
people off if you're noticing this this
idea that we have to take all of these
old movies that were classics
yeah and just remake them with women as
if as if the women can't watch the old
one you see it's I mean the Ghostbusters
is the easiest example is I mean when
they did the all women remake I watch it
I didn't I have no problem watching an
all woman cast of host Buster's but the
movie was freakin hard yeah no one no
one cares about this stuff like this is
the thing about this thing you don't
need to educate these fans like
particular science fiction fan
particular comic book fans you know
they've done this a lot with sort of
changing the genders and the the race
and the sexual orientation of various
major characters and so these are
already The Outsiders these comic book
fans these are people who have no issues
with this you
it's like someone it's like a school
mistress sort of finger pointing and
jabbing at people when they don't need
that education it generates a lot of
resentment people hate it do you think
it's also
sort of funny I think especially with
the gay thing the way that they sneak in
these messages so I'm like like the two
that I could think of and I'm sure you
have like a gajillion more but the two
that really struck me is like they're
just like smacking you with this in the
worst way yeah is in Avengers endgame
yeah they had the one gay character was
just the guy in rehab yeah who I guess
maybe went on a date with a guy in
Captain America is like good for you
like that I was throwing the gays like
the tiniest bones yeah yeah nobody did
it was just like I see we did something
gay yeah that's nothing to do with the
superheroes or anyone you give a [ __ ]
about but it's something gay yeah and
then the other one was in in rise of
Skywalker yeah we're at the end that
woman has that lesbian kiss and it's
like again it's not a real character
it's not anyone anyone cares about but
we did something for the case so it's
just like take our little pity what
that's not yeah but it also like the
case don't need your pity right mean it
like I don't need to see pink
stormtroopers and I don't need to see
gay people in Star Wars for me to feel
okay about stuff you know it's okay
anyway there's been c-3po for years
there has been getting a plantation and
all of this star was gross it's not a
minority view to have been in a robo
sexual relations yeah explicit yeah and
I don't need to see that I mean they did
you know they did the same with Avengers
like you say they did the same with the
the JK Rowling the fantastic beasts
stuff and they were saying that it
wasn't gay enough he said there's the
points you've got Dumbledore but it's
not explicitly gay enough what do you
want to see you want to see him I want
to see him I know getting fisted or
something like I mean they say is that
really what you need I kind of say that
I'm sorry I don't know I mean I don't
need I don't know that people want to
hear you say you know I know sure I'm
getting fisted I don't write I think
it's really patronizing yeah I think
ultimately that's what it is like so so
much of what drives what I do is I hate
the way these people patronize minority
groups I hate that because I think
they're it's the opposite of what they
say it is right so if you claim to be
fourth wave feminism right which claims
to be all about empowerment of women
it's not it's about treating them like
children about victimizing them it's
actually genuinely misogynistic but it's
but it's sort of papered over with this
kind of sheen of we're doing something
progressive that I don't think there's
anything progressive about any of this
stuff and the other thing I hate about
it is I think it legitimizes bullying I
think the social justice movement that's
I I hate bullies I can't stand them
right and and if you if you stand up
against them they get even more vicious
right you must have noticed this right
so it's it's funny all of the signals
about how
you are like putting pronouns in your
bio on Twitter or putting a rainbow flag
up there on Twitter why is it whenever I
get brutally attacked on Twitter those
are the people when I go to their bio Oh
Pro knows what and I'm not saying that
the the pronouns themselves are all or
making a connection with trans people I
wanted a legitimate answer to this so
that's this question before why is it
the case that the most vicious the most
bullying or the most unpleasant
characteristics tend to come from those
people I don't know why it's so
interesting I mean I have some theories
as to which maybe we should a little bit
but it's only because I just last week I
tweeted something to that effect why are
the worst people on Twitter yeah
angriest people it always is the he/him
they pee yeah or the they have all the
flags or all the other things now again
I have no problem with trans people
obviously and I have no problem if you
know the general idea of justice if you
mean equality yes yes but why are they
why are they also I mean I think the
reason for that is it has something to
do with personal responsibility right I
mean they've sort of they've they've
outsourced their person or
responsibilities so they don't have to
take care of their own lives
it's just be angry at the system as
opposed to mainly I don't sit up with
your shoulders back as that guy said
maybe maybe I mean I imagine a lot of
the people are well-intentioned I
imagine if in your mind you've converted
someone into this monster this Nazi this
issue then then it legitimizes you being
horrible to that person but of course
the the instinct to be horrible to
another human being is an instinct that
we all have that we have to keep down
and make sure that well that's why we're
civilized we're civilized out of that
kind of behavior and it worries me that
this kind of thing legitimizes that
stuff and I I don't like it but but
likewise I don't wanna demonize people
who put pronouns in their bio that's up
to them it's not as not an issue but why
is that correlation there you you have a
theory I don't know what the I don't
know what yeah well someone said if you
stare into the abyss the abyss might
just stare back someone didn't say that
someone said that yeah there's something
to that you know I mean they start
becoming everything that well they're
not doing themselves any favors and this
is the things because I think you and I
you know we both care about opposing
racism opposing homophobia opposing
sexism all of those things and what
upsets me about this stuff is it makes
those those causes look stupid it makes
them look daft I mean there was the
couple years ago in Philadelphia when
they the the gay pride march changed the
gay rainbow flag
and they had a black stripe and a brown
stripe and they did the same in
Manchester last year for Manchester
pride and they were saying it wasn't
racially inclusive they need a black and
because as though the rainbow flag is a
literal representation of the skin
colours that are acceptable in the gay
community you know yeah and I had to
Tania write about this because she was
saying oh well a minute the rainbow in
the sky isn't and got a black and brown
stripe so we need to petition
meteorologists to find a way we're going
to modify the process of refraction and
dispersal to make sure that the
electromagnetic spectrum isn't racist
you know the and because it is it is
that ludicrous but is that isn't that
bad irony that they're the ones that
thus inject racism into everything so
right like nobody in their right mind no
clear thinking person ever thought the
rainbow flag in and of itself right was
excluding anybody that point was you're
gay or something by whatever the hell
you are go to the parade Zippity damn
duda it's your and then they're the ones
that say now race has to sit on top of
right well this is the intersectional
thing and this is why I'm I'm of the
view that we should just ditch the
rainbow flag and it and ditch the LGBTQ
acronym yeah I I you know lgbtqia+ or
whatever it is now and I they keep
changing it I think we need to ditch it
I think what this stuff is doing is
dividing us up as much as possible
making things much much worse and you
know III stopped short of saying that it
is homophobia racism as such I think
it's it's it's a new kind of racialized
thinking which isn't isn't helpful it
means that you're hyper
I mean being aware of racial issues is
important right I think but being hyper
aware to the point that you only see
that or you see that first and foremost
but isn't that racist I know what you're
saying you don't want to push that last
moment to go from you're trying to give
them the benefit of the doubt that it's
not racist it's not you believe no
because I think I think racism has to be
about intention that's why I that I
think I get why you'd want to call it
racist but I think because it is about
intention III would step back from that
I think what they think they genuinely
believe what they're saying but they
think all of them do this has come up
with a lot of my guests you know that
there's sort of the foot soldier
versions of it and then there's the
people that are really stoking it so
like in America like I would say Linda
Sarsour and a lot of the Bernese the
arrogance they're really stoking this
hatred I would say they're bad actors so
but the average genderless person on
Twitter
I think it's just being 19 year old is
just being used by them so I think my my
stance on that is what are you I always
assume people are telling the truth even
if I suspect they're not I know that
sounds contradictory but explain the
reason for that is I think part of the
problem that we have with political
discussion and debate and discourse at
the moment is that everyone's just
imagining what the other person is
thinking and they're arguing against
that so in effect their argument gates
themselves so what I say is well look if
you can defeat the argument the argument
is defeated irrespective of whether they
mean it or not so just focus on that you
know I mean Linda Sarsour argument it's
a you know she comes across as quite an
unpleasant individual and I'm sure that
maybe she has got some bad potentially
but I'm not gonna assume that because I
could be wrong I really could be wrong
yeah you know well okay fine but you
know I don't know the man by the way I
mean she was getting the platform they
wanted to deprive her from her from her
from Queens College yeah I defended her
and I got a lot of [ __ ] for it but I
didn't defend her as a person I defended
the idea that if she was invited you got
well from what from a pragmatic the
interview right it's it's better just to
address the arguments as and when they
come but also it strengthens your own
position because that's what people do
with me all the time I mean ninety-eight
percent of the arguments I have on
Twitter are people telling me what I
think about things and getting a hundred
percent wrong so if I'm if I'm not going
to I have to get extend the same
courtesy right and I think that's and we
all have to do that I think otherwise
we're going to be constantly fighting
with shadows and ghosts can you talk a
little bit about how this stuff sort of
infected or at least from from my
perspective seems to have infected the
Labour Party in the UK yeah maybe why it
did
so that's your lefty party for people
yes so the Labour Party is the jeremy
corbyn's party on the Lenni jeremy
corbyn comes from a very old old-school
socialists I'd like a Bernie Sanders
kind of figure and those sorts of people
don't sit well with woke politics it
doesn't it doesn't actually work because
they're class-conscious
and what you'll find with most of the
social justice activists they don't care
about class issues and the reason they
don't is a lot of them are rich so you
know it doesn't really affect them you
know and the Labour Party then found
itself in this muddle it had jeremy
corbyn announcing his pronouns before
speaking it had one of their members
Harriet Harman saying that she was going
to create a pink bus to tour the country
to try and encourage women to get into
politics okay so this very kind of
patronizing because they just see pink
oh my god why wouldn't you know if you
see a pink bus yeah yeah I'm sorry
minutes andum so all of that kind of
stuff and it and because there's now
this correlation between this this woke
idea and left-wing politics I don't
think there's anything left wing about
it right but it's been sort of seized
upon people who call themselves
left-wing but don't really know the
difference between left and right
and it's infected the party to such
degree but actually having said that
these sort of ideas have also infected
the right wing parties so you know I'm
constantly told well because I claimed
to be fighting against an establishment
okay but of course you Trump sin power
over here Boris Johnson's in power over
in the UK so we have right-wing
governments right ostensibly but that
said culturally speaking and indeed even
within the government departments you
still have some work ideas going on and
sort of driving the narrative so that's
what happened with labour I think I
think the other big thing with Labour's
brexit so bricks it became a sort of
linchpin for the woke mob to latch on to
and what they did is they do what they
always do they turned it into something
it didn't mean so they said the brexit
vote is about whether you're racist or
not you're voting yes I'm racist or no
I'm not racist no what it really was is
do we want to remain in a neoliberal
trading bloc that's what it really was
but that's not what the debate was about
so it got misinterpreted misconstrued
and then the Labour Party when they ran
this time said they were going to
support a second referendum to try and
undo what just happened that kind of
authoritarian instinct rerunning a
referendum saying you the people got it
wrong that's that's one point
oh that's straight that's right there
but at the end of the day is it because
they don't really care sort of about
what's right like in a way they don't
care about democracy they don't care
that the people voted for brexit they
care that they have enough power to use
as a crutch all over the people to come
they want I think again there's a lot
well-meaning people in the Labour Party
I think again I think they've convinced
themselves through a process of the last
three years that the people didn't know
what they were voting for right so when
I spoke to a member of Corbin's Shadow
Cabinet
just after the election sorry just after
the brexit vote back 2016 and she said
there's no way we're going to reverse
this this is going to happen and and
actually as it happened they all did try
eventually and I think it's that process
of convincing yourself that people were
misinformed that there were they just
did what Russian bloc BOTS hold them to
you know you have the same over here
with Trump your people almost everything
that I say is from Russia but really by
a Russian burger
it's a really lazy thing which people do
when they don't want to deal with the
fact that some people don't agree with
them you know you can't run a democracy
that way one of the things that
frightens me the most and it's happened
over here as well as you know is that
this thing of the losers consent isn't
really present anymore you know we have
to have a situation in a democratic
society where we we come to terms with
the fact that a substantial portion of
the population are going to be led by
people they did not vote for and we all
accept that ya know if we lose we have
to accept them but it's like the most
important thing it's so important right
and and that's been led astray and I
think that's to do with with the the
this this social justice mentality and I
am very aware when I talk about this
like because social justice sounds so
wonderful and it sounds like I'm
knocking something that's really good
same with the woke word I mean the word
woke comes from the black civil rights
movement and and I actually see that
that was appropriated by these people
right I'm you know the black civil
rights movement the gay rights movement
of the 60s the new left the feminist
movement that was all gray and they knew
that free speech was important and this
lot come along and they try and unpick
all of that stuff undo it all right
reverse it that's why I call them
reactionaries because that's what it
means it means that you're uncomfortable
with change and that's the word that's
thrown at people like us all the time
it's then they're the ones that are
uncomfortable they're the ones that
think the civil rights movement got it
wrong right right well even though you
could just see an MLK day they start
turning on the things that MLK said I
mean this idea that you should judge
people on the content of their character
yeah that doesn't really work I woke
calculator how long before they before
they completely deep platform email
killed or canceled him I wonder I've got
a bit in the new titania book I've just
written where she rewrites his I have a
dream speech because she wants to be
about intersectionality she wanted to be
about judging the color of his skin not
the continuity character you know she
she wants to um he was a bigot they're
gay right exactly what so itself hated
black man and that's it that
internalized racism yeah I guess do you
think that some of this is starting to
turn partly through comedy and through
art so we sort of we mock the the Star
Wars Avengers version of this but your
national hero JK Rowling yeah did put up
a tweet that had a certain anti
diversity
did you see the backlash yeah can you
tell the good part about what happened
there yes so what happened was there's a
woman called Maya for starter who was
there was a tribunal in the UK because
she'd been dismissed from her work
because of some tweets she'd send or
Facebook posts they think where she
basically said that she believes that
you cannot change sexually thinks that
biology is immutable and that we have
immutable biological characteristics
which is her opinion and she has the
right to that opinion and her point was
not not to disrespect trans man he was
just I mean we go through this every
freaking week but right well she was
just saying is that biology exists right
sure that was in essence which one of us
like what Blair White said like if there
is no biological sex there's no such
thing as trans right you know so it's
but she was you know irrespective of the
people being angry about her opinion it
was the fact that she was fired that was
scary and then it was the fact that a
judge in the UK said that that was not
something you were allowed to that you
could legitimately be fired for saying
something like that so that's what's a
bit scary about so JK Rowling merely
tweeted and said I support this this
woman she was saying you should be able
to sleep with everyone and identify her
you won the liberal position yeah she's
a lefty alright and I think on this
stuff you've got to take the liberal
position you've got witches anyone has
the right to identify however they like
to live the life however that to call
themselves whatever they want well they
don't have the right to do it it's
demand that someone else calls that of
course on those things like to to to
monitor and police someone else's
language I mean if I get married to my
boyfriend and I say to someone I want
you to call this person my husband but
they're a Christian fundamentalist they
say I don't recognize that I'm not gonna
I can't force that person to do so I can
argue with them I can explain to them
why I think it would be polite and
that's my right but it's their right
totally legitimately their right not to
not to do so the best thing wouldn't be
to call them a Nazi and then try to get
the state power to put them in jail it's
weird it's not persuasive you know it's
so weird though isn't it I don't know
why it's it's it's not a good strategic
thing to do you know and I think we've
learned that there are the past few
years we have but all right so JK
basically offers a defense of what this
work ed and then everyone got everyone
go mad right everyone goes mad because
everyone that says she's a transfer band
which she absolutely is not yeah and and
and and also she committed the cardinal
sin right so you know the artists
particularly one way inclined there's a
kind of very homogeneous group think
amongst artists amongst comedians
particularly and you get a lot of flack
if you don't quite subscribe to those
ideas and
she did that's why I don't think it's
going to be from arts and creatives that
this thing changes because they're part
of the problem Sophie honest I don't
really I don't think it is going to come
from that but when you see like Ricky
Gervais is at the Golden Globes where he
just scorched yeah everything that this
book is about and the hypocrisy of Holly
yeah and just all of the awful ideas of
intersectionality and all of those
things yeah that's got to give you a
little hope but it does but but I mean
that was brilliant but that's because he
can he's in a position to do what he
wants you know when he did that speech
there were a lot of even comics and the
even famous left-wing comics in the
country were saying oh he's now like a
right-wing yeah electrically him
right-wing saying as a writer he's part
of the establishment these are the very
same people that like 10 years ago would
have cheered him attacking the hypocrisy
of the most pampered people on the
planet let's face it you know and he was
there to do that job but to call that
right-wing is is depressing now I don't
think it's going to come from artists
and creative it that he can do that
because he he he's answerable to no one
like he's in he's in that MB of enviable
position but if you're working a normal
job you can't do that you can't say
these things if people are it isn't
about state censorship it's about self
censorship it's about the fact that
people feel really nervous about what
they say at the moment and I know I
don't you know I wish I could I don't
want to speak ill of artists and stuff
cuz I love them and I you know I I have
an ingrained respect for anyone who
wants to create something but I think
they're I think they're part of the
problem rather than the solution you
know do you think that gay men for some
reason have a unique position and
standing up to this thing for some you
know anything like that seems to me that
there's a series of people you're going
on tour with Douglas Mari yeah for the
first year that I had read Douglas and
stuff I didn't even know he was gay now
we've become good friends and yeah he's
he's truly out there talking about this
stuff and he does a really interesting
dissection of why you should separate
the the T from the LGBT thing yeah but
it does seem to me that there's a bunch
of gay men that are sort of leading the
fight against this do you think there's
a reason for that there's something well
there's the conflict I think between
certain elements of the extreme trans
ideology which just doesn't sit well
with gay rights you know because they
would say that you can't be same gen
same-sex attracted right and that
because they don't want to see biology
you know and and
that's a problem for for gay men I think
there is a fundamental problem there
also I think I think it comes from free
freedom thought I think a lot of gay
people particularly maybe slightly the
older maybe the the generations X
generation you did have to sort of think
for yourself you know a lot of gay
people were growing up when I were
growing up they ended up in straight
relationships and straight marriages you
know but the ones who could sort of
think for themselves and think outside
the box were the ones who sort of
embraced who they were wait that's
interesting so a lot of gay people that
you knew maybe 20 years ago ended up in
heterosexual imagine yeah something sort
of like meaning meaning that they became
straight or meaning that they just sort
of couldn't fight the I know I don't
think I think idea of normalcy or
something that well you know back then
it was a very different world I mean
everything about society did coach you
to be straight and sort of and you did
just assume that you that you were
mm-hmm
and so I think it takes a certain kind
of mindset to understand that actually
or not to accept that you're not and I
very different now you know we live in a
totally different world now we have
everything's everything's completely
equal and everything's everything's fine
but yeah I do know some people I mean I
don't want to name names but I know some
people who are in straight relationships
but they're not really insofar as they
you know they double and right and I
think that's it's just a generational
thing yeah well plus now we were in
endgame with that guy the psychologist I
haven't actually seen yeah yeah I mean
it's literally it's the most pathetic
they're sitting like a self oh yeah like
one guy is like I survived you know what
happened at the end it won't light
anymore I survived it and I went on a
date man we've happened America is like
Oh God well I I don't like superhero
films firstly so I'm gonna put that out
there but also I just think they're
silly they're people flying around in
capes I can't get on board with that
yeah [ __ ] with Batman even the Dark
Knight when one says it's really serious
I it makes me laugh it's silly yeah yeah
it's for kids
but but yeah the old I doesn't like
capes
exactly I know and I'm Catholic I mean
no but that thing about all I know is I
read an article in The Guardian about if
an end game and it said it was great but
the fat shaming broke my heart and I
just thought come on oh because they say
me that yeah they made Thor fat
you know but this made quite funny about
Norse God letting himself go or is it
was funny but even that that's I'm glad
you brought that up actually cuz that's
been popping up lately that now if you
say anything about people better fact
that I didn't I don't like mocking or
bullying someone that sighs you know I
think that's wait but it's like you're
almost not allowed to say that being fit
or eating right or taking care of
yourself is actually something you
should aspire to well we all inherently
know he's taught us the problems I mean
we all do it all the time a lot of
people had to go at Cancer Research UK
which is a charity in the UK they
recently put a number of posters up on
the tube to saying that obesity is now
the highest form the most common form of
cancer or the most common cause of
cancer it's actually overtaking smoking
and then a lot of social justice
activists went crazy and saying you're
fat shaming you're gonna cause more
deaths it's like and calling them some
really unpleasant were these are good
people these are good people who are
trying to help people you know I think
there's not there's nothing I mean you
don't want to mock or attack people for
their size but on the same token it's
not good to tell kids it doesn't matter
what you eat it doesn't matter
however weight you are because they're
gonna die younger like that's that's it
you know and I think why can't we just
accept medical reality yeah you know
it's really am I gonna get accused of
fat shaming for saying no no it's very
clear you're fat ofoh bore a weight of
over something something so when you
first came out with titania was that the
character wasn't originally associated
with you fully right I was in the closet
yeah you were in the closet and then you
were outed I was outed yeah yeah can you
so I totally so you create this
character I wanted to be anonymous yeah
and it just meant that I was free to say
whatever I wasn't worried about it maybe
what happened was I wrote the book and
then in the week that the book came out
there was a bit of press interest about
it and so there was a journalist at the
Sunday Times
Rosamond Owen I think her name was who
did some investigative work and sort of
dug up she read a lot of my political
articles and she and she'd read that her
an advance copy of the book and she
worked out some of the quotations with
some of them his really good job like a
real jerk probably mr. Gela so far and
she whittled it down to me and a friend
of mine Lisa Graves who runs a character
called Jarvis Department and if you
follow him he's a really funny
no parody a catch and a her sorry she's
just transitioned and so she whittled it
down to us yeah and then a comedy
website called chortle found the smoking
gun some sort of wrote a book festival
brochure which accidentally named me it
was someone from the publisher
accidentally named me as the author so
and that happened wouldn't wait when you
had signed the deal for the book yeah
did you have a Shirin psa's from your
publisher that just verbal you know I
you know we just decided it would be
better if I didn't come out yeah it just
so happened that it came out the week
the book was published and and that
ended up with a lot of publicity as a
result of that and the story then became
that it was me who was behind the who's
behind the character but the only
difference is I've never changed the way
she speaks I've never changed the
character I've never sent to myself the
the only difference is that now whenever
I tweet something that maybe is a bit
contentious I get the attacks I got the
deluge I had it recently where I tweeted
a joke and loads and it was an
anti-racist joke it was mocking a racist
I stereotype and people of course
because they're very literal-minded
interpreted it as being a racist joke
right and so I got lots of people
attacking me online personally and call
me racist and not seeing all the rest of
it so that's the downside of it so
everything being equal you would have
preferred to have kept these two
personas yeah where the human and the
persona separate just just for an
artistic freedom right yeah and also
yeah I I would and it's nice it's nice
because you get into a character you
start to think like her I started to
dream as her I know this isn't healthy
but all of that sort of stuff I like
that I like the idea of inventing
characters and writing behind characters
and it also affects the interpretation
because now people interpret the
character on the basis of my personal
politics or misinterpret as the case may
be right so so as someone that is that
at least originally intended to be an
anonymous character online that is no
longer anonymous what's your take on
just generally like the tenor of what
people talk about on social media and
how much of it is done through anonymous
accounts oh loads of it is like that's
why it's such a cess pit right I mean
it's it's it's a the thing about Twitter
and the thing about all of that stuff is
that people are for the anonymity frees
them up to be horrible to be even worse
than to say things that they never would
even when they're not anonymous I've had
situations where
people have said the most horrible
things online when you meet them there
it's a different story no no they don't
want to so that element of it
but on the other hand it does enable I
think you should be able to have
satirical accounts and parody counts and
all the rest of sort of stuff so I think
it's a good thing yeah do you sense now
after the JK Rowling thing that we
discussed and enough of these
conversations like what do you sense
would be the thing that would you need
to get us to the tipping point where we
start yet maybe are we starting to get
there I'm sensing that something's
happening and yet at least maybe through
the American election now I tweeted at
the beginning of the year that this is
the year it implodes because it can't
okay the intersectional thing can't hold
for an election like this and and it's
partly what you said about why Jeremy
Corbyn doesn't fit in my will Windsor
sexual thing I think we have a version
of that with Bernie here to do I mean we
know that intersectional identity
politics loses elections right mark
Lilla wrote about this in his book the
once and future liberal we know we know
that across the board that always
happens right identity politics that
Hillary Clinton died dividing people up
into their gender their race and
everything say I'm going to target this
demographic and that's doesn't work
right so and worldwide it doesn't work
which is why the right is winning
basically everywhere right now here's
the problem you have though is that the
intersectional left for want of a better
term they come up with this premise and
their premise is that they know that
anyone who is right-wing is secretly a
fascist anyone who votes for Donald
Trump is secretly announcing okay so
then when he wins they pointed out and
say that's evidence that our premise was
right so you know after the last one and
I wrote this some Jonathan pie video
about the Hillary Clinton losing and
saying it was her you know it was the
left the left knee to reevaluate their
position they need to rethink about the
way they're going but they didn't they
double down they made it worse I
genuinely at that point thought they
would there would be a period of
self-reflection I think we all annoyed
it yeah but but what they did instead is
they said this proves all of our worst
fears it's a kind of circular reasoning
thing and that's my that's why I worry
it might not get better that quickly
because if Trump wins again which I'm
pretty convinced he will then what will
happen is they'll say they'll say that
is further evidence that we live in this
crypto-fascist state and they'll just
make they'll just accelerate or the
crazy mania that they've been doing over
the past few years do you think
our institutions are able to stand up
against this so this is sort of what you
hinted before about what's happening
with Bragg's it with you guys but even
what we see out of the left now they
want to get rid of the electoral college
they want to add Supreme Court justices
they don't want states rights like these
these are now structural things yeah
that I think if Trump wins again which I
agree he's going to you know short of
some really cataclysmic thing happening
yeah that what their their move is going
to be well not only do you figure out a
new way to try to impeach him and just
you know you just don't accept elections
and yeah but it will be to attack every
one of the last vestiges of our
functioning democracy I think so and
that's why I think we need to think of
it we do need to seriously consider the
tactics here and you know I've gone for
the satirical route you know I you know
I also write argumentative arc articles
but let's face it these people aren't
really willing to be persuaded I mean
they often won't turn up to debates or
arguments because they don't want to
discuss yeah but you said to me right
before we started you do something that
I do which is that if someone has a Q&A
you try to bring up people that disagree
with you first that's what I want more
than anything I want I want the
discussion to be opened up you know at
the moment it's not so I think
tactically we have to think about
setting an example right so anyone who
believes in freedom and liberty needs to
we need to firstly ditch this guilt by
association thing right so we need to be
able to talk to people we don't agree
with you know if I if I appear on a show
when I appeared on with Tucker Carson on
fox news and people accuse me of being
the same as him it's like I'm sorry I'm
sure we had disagree on all sorts of
things but he was really nice to me
about the book we had a good discussion
about the book it was great and then
when we met six months ago we met in the
Fox affiliate here in LA we were both
doing Tucker at different different
times I was walking out as you were
walking in and it was like do we both
have disagreements with Tucker of course
I brought those disagreements up in
public with Tucker yes
I'm not gonna play that game anymore and
I think more people need to say look
first if we need to stop accusing people
of guilt by association so just because
you talk to someone doesn't mean you
sort of by osmosis sort of take on board
all of their beliefs and ideas that's
the first thing right I think we need to
reinstate a kind of critical thinking in
schools at the lowest level and what I
mean I used to teach critical thinking
at a level and it was seen as kind of
like the DOS subject right well you talk
about the basics know things like if you
throw an insult if you start mudslinging
you've lost the are
that's it it's over for you right well
no one believes that now do they well
even the politicians don't believe that
now so we need to reinstate that idea
you need to listen to what other people
are saying you need to not into it the
motive of what the other people are
saying you need to not translate what
they're saying into something they
haven't said mischaracterize your
opponent which is the straw man thing
all of that stuff so it needs to start
in schools but then the other big
problem is universities we need to
somehow and I don't know how to do that
but I think maybe just going after the
social justice warriors as I do and I
don't even like that phrase social
justice worries because I think it's a
kind of demonizing term I think just
just mocking and poking at that beast
will only agitate the beast and I think
there's got to be something that we do
that is a bit more ground-level you know
what I mean like some things and I think
it is to do with education well it's
funny because whenever I give talks at
colleges this always comes up yeah kids
will always say to me well what do you
do how do you I have a friend that's
been overtaken by this thing or what do
I do and I always say that the but I
think the best thing you can do is just
to be a little bit better than they are
yeah every time you're in a conversation
and then they jump on you and attack you
try to just be a little bit better and
it doesn't mean just endlessly take crap
yeah it doesn't mean just be beaten into
oblivion but if you consistently try to
be a little bit better and at the end
instead of just you know walking out of
a restaurant and telling them you're
never gonna see them again easy yeah
yeah we'll pick this up again it's a
yeah you know why it's so hard because I
I mean you're pretty good at this on
Twitter and I'm I try but I fail all the
time so do I I mean if someone comes to
you and says you're a [ __ ] Nazi scum
who should burn in hell right so I my
instinct is to fight back I do believe
you should stand up for you stand up
against bullies all the time right now
my thing is started to mock them or get
richest and I and I've sort of taught
myself not to I think it's wrong and
there's a way to do it
actually I you know what I think if
someone comes to you in that way I think
you just lock them I think you need to
get rid of them right because because my
role on Twitter is is if someone said
that to me to my face on the street so
someone came up to me and says you're an
Oakley box headed Nazi scumbag would I
say okay well let's let's talk about
that little more let's tease out your
the nuances of your argument there I
wouldn't do that
I'd probably walk away right and so the
equipment's gonna be on Twitter but I
mean I've never blocked someone on
Twitter for just disagreeing if you come
with me with something with a
disagreement right disagreement
let's have it let's talk about it I
always think the funniest thing is when
I see like you know people that I know
that are many of them have books here
like great academics great thinkers yeah
yeah an online torrents and yet online
they're literally arguing with pink
anime foxes yeah and it's like you have
day one already
pink Adam a fox for the win yeah because
the fact that you gave the many of your
attention and yet we all get sucked into
this monster it's quite funny that was
never I love anything that bursts a
pretentious bubble when you see an
academic saying [ __ ] you yeah throw down
the emojis it's like now you don't need
to footnote that one you know that's not
that's not sophisticated yeah are you
shocked that so much of this we've
talked a little bit from a UK
perspective an American perspective but
that this is happening all over the
world at once yeah cuz I get as much
email you know I just had a couple of
Swedes on the show talking about how
they've been completely their whole
societies been completely infected by
this but I get as much email from from
Australia and yada and I n a ton from
India actually there's there's something
really something's happening in India
getting a ton of email from India lately
that all over the world this thing has
but this is my virus has spread but this
is why I don't think it's on his way
down I mean I know like you know it's so
tempting like when you see a thing like
the Draco drowning thing or something
like every now and then to think oh
that's it the tides about to turn but it
isn't really I mean it is spreading and
yeah it's absolutely international it's
mostly in the english-speaking countries
at the moment but it but it is spreading
beyond there I well you know it's funny
when I just took totally clarify one
yeah when I say it's gonna implode this
year I don't mean it's going to be
destroyed like stamped out what I think
is that the American election is going
to cause it to be fully exposed okay so
that for the masses that aren't really
paying attention to this many more of
them will realize how bad it is okay
that's so right like I don't think
they're gonna settle there's no evidence
as you were saying that they're gonna
suddenly be like oh we lost another
election yeah we should stop calling
everyone Nazis that's not gonna happen
but I think that for them for that group
of people that are just sitting on the
sidelines that kind of watch this and
they're like yeah what's going on here
I think something so crazy is going to
happen in our election and we can feel
it already
Hillary you know Warren calls Bernie a
sexist you know yeah Booker gets out so
now they're all racists like all of
these things it's gonna just become so
obvious that I think we're gonna be able
to get more of the whatever that middle
maybe something like that maybe it's
because of the majority people aren't
into this stuff you know it's always
been the case that it's just a minority
of people and it's excuse me it's a
minority with a lot of power that's
that's ultimately what it is right it's
it's I mean I've said this before but I
I do believe that the woke left are
dominant in the media in arts in
journalism in the law in education in
quangos government quangos does it say
something about those jobs do you think
it's it's it's probably relating to
class it's probably relate mean that
there's a good reason why the work
movement is predominately bourgeois
right they come from privately educated
backgrounds on the whole and it's you
know you've never had to struggle for
anything and and and there is some sort
of odd desire to be oppressed this odd
desire to be a victim I don't I don't
really understand that and I guess
that's the correlation I think so I
don't know so you have another book have
another book coming out when a book
about in spring I'm not I think it's
early May where were a total anyone the
title is my first little book of
intersectional activism so this is a
children's it's a children's book by
titania McGrath yeah yeah she got after
the kids market yeah you know just want
to miss a trend ya know cuz you've had
this you've had loads of these woke
children's books right yeah the books
like good night stories for girls and
see is for consent there was that one
there's a the little girl forgave zero
positive it's for lots of things yeah
yeah exactly it's all of these little
children's books which are basically
about intersectionality and about white
privilege and mansplaining and all this
sort stuff now I think it's really funny
these books are doing really well by the
way and that there's a there's a
guarding journalist in the UK who's like
independently millionaire very wealthy
she wrote one about the Supreme Court
and so everyone's getting on this so I
thought she would I thought to Tony
would totally do that
yeah but the thing is so just finished
the book and she gets it all wrong like
she can't speak to children she doesn't
know she she still uses the jargon and
expects them to understand all the words
you know because when she was born she
claims that when she was born her first
words were seize the means of production
you know so she thinks that kids just
understand this stuff yeah so yeah it's
been really fun and I'm going to make it
look like a proper children's book with
illustrations and all the rest of it
yeah it's gonna be horribly
inappropriate and then you're going on
tour with mr. Douglas Murray
with Douglas Murray which is great I
think so the tour is called resisting
woken Asst which sounds quite
provocative I suppose but what I really
want to do is get people to discuss this
stuff right people are feeling that
they're not there in a society where
they they don't feel that able or
comfortable to tell say what they
believe to be true anymore so we want
people to come along and have that
discussion and we're going to go around
the UK we're gonna end up at the
Hammersmith Apollo in London and we're
gonna it's basically we're going to be
talking to the issues trying to actually
work the issues out and we've even
talking to you today like there are
things that I'm not clear on and I want
to talk more about it - - and I'm
willing to be persuaded you know this is
the this is the the main reason I think
we're talking to people you don't agree
with is you might be wrong like there
are all sorts of things I'm probably
almost certainly wrong about and I want
to know what they are I mean yeah you
can say you know I can argue with people
to refine my argument that's a selfish
perspective I think it should be
well actually it's good to be proven
wrong isn't it so Douglas and I are
going to tour it and it's really good
because we come from different political
backgrounds you know we know this is a
conservative he's accepted we have
different views on all sorts of things
on this matter we share the same
concerns I found it so weird over the
past few years though I've made all
these new allies these new friends
that's actually that was where I wanted
to go just for the I'm anticipating yeah
no boy I got it I guess I don't even
need to ask you a question but but
through all of this that you know that
you have been through and writing books
and being in the Twitter fights and the
world of this and and talking about
something that's so culturally relevant
yeah are you shocked
by the people on the right because I
still cuz I sometimes I'm still shocked
by how welcoming these people are yeah
and I still one of the things that the
the you know the genderless anonymous
people on Twitter will say Dave you know
the rights being nice to you now but
they're just using you right they're
just using you as if I'm some sort of
like incapacitated yeah you know you
mean it's like you know I have no
volition over my own thoughts exactly
and it's like I think that I have seen
great intellectual flexibility with
these people I don't agree with him on
everything
yeah portion and a few other things you
know what I mean but but they're willing
to talk it out that the truth is that
the boring truth is that most people are
nice
basically you know the vast majority
people are just decent and you've just
got the extremes on both sides who
discolor the entire movement whatever
movement they're a part of
you know it's like the trans activists
on the whole are decent people with the
minority the really angry violent group
them that just you know really make it
hard for all the others and and so we've
got the same thing what I have no I mean
I'll be honest most because I come from
the comedy circuit right so most of my
friends have always been on the left
okay and then and I and you know I've
heard these people demonize the people
you're not meant to talk to I've heard
the mischaracterized and then now doing
what I'm doing a lot of conservative
like what I do which is great and and
they and you meet them and they're
really great and some of the people in
particular who I've been told steer
clear from have turned out to be just
the sweetest nicest people and they're
nothing like the public persona and the
irony is some of my friends that I've
lost who are famous lefties have turned
out to be the monsters they've turned
out to be the bigots the ones who will I
had one guy shouting at me in a bar
called me a Nazi over and over again I'm
thinking I mean you're not a good person
you know and it's it's really it's
really sad but I mean I did this some
conference in London recently with Peter
Bogosian and James Lindsay and Helen
plug crows which this was something
which was organized by a group called
sovereign nations who are you know it's
run by a guy who's Michael O'Fallon who
is a you know evangelical Christian yeah
right weighing right plant Toby he could
yet leave he was doing an event yeah
sure thing yet these people were amazing
and such a nice guy though and then you
get the event and I'm sitting there at
lunch with like the head of the Atheist
Society next to it like oh and of
evangelical pastor left-wing people
driving people Muslim Christian atheist
and you just think this is what's
happening now so it's like it's people
are finding these alliances of people
it's not about left and right now right
we have to get rid of that it's about if
you believe in Liberty or if you want a
thority figures to run everything this
Liberty versus Authority which is
something that John Stuart Mill talked
about that's where the alliances come
it's people who who want freedom and I
think it doesn't matter if your
right-wing or left-wing or whatever if
you believe in that then we've got
something in common and we and we can
talk about that and the other thing is
we all have to get together and work for
this because if we lose that we can't
have all the other conversations we want
to have about abortion about gay rights
about whatever because nothing happens
if you don't have freedom of speech
you've got nothing I often say it I
don't know what it says about me but I
have
on Liberty in my nightstand do you I
have yeah it's totally available people
I think people are intimidated by
because we've written a long time ago
but it's readable it's thin it's thinner
the memo is quite big font yeah it's
yeah it's thin it's it's great it's
intersectional because his wife helped
him write it you know which he often
doesn't get credit for you know there's
a lot there's a lot going on in that
book and it's articulately expressed and
it and and we you know we need to get
back to those core principles of Liberty
and that should be the standard points
that you are allowed to argue with me
and disagree and say whatever you want
you just can't you can't arrest me you
can't beat me up and and that's that
that should be the limit but people
don't agree with that anymore today
Andrew Doyle you are a true radical I
don't know that I can have you back here
but cb2 controversial but we'll see okay
I'm gonna have to see what the
Twitterati thinks about this I know what
they think about me so should we send
people to I always send people to a
Twitter account but I don't know
Catania's or well it depends what you
want if you want to send abuse go to me
that's Andrew Doyle underscore calm yeah
and if you want to go for titania she's
to Tonya McGrath simple as that you
brought it to a close thanks buddy if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell